gebietsverluste gibt die man dann mit
umgesetzt wurden aber von teilautonomie
zum westen und was zum osten gehört sie
ist der sport offen sagt die koalition
das musste er sagen hat und nicht so zu
checkpoints der russen vorbei der mann
zum presseclub nachgefragt hier auf
hörte man muss ihm auch zu hören wollen
braucht man nicht nur kiew und moskau
die bundeswehr die zeitenwende sollte ja
ringtausch mit slowenien gemacht weil
wir es halt von daher als es ist ich das
erst nötig da war auch dass es eine
volker herres hallo und herzlich
gerne möchte da noch eine sehr große
innerkoalitionären druck geliefert
länger dauert irgendwann werden die
wieder die nächste stunde der wahrheit
also die entspannungs politik will ich
reicht uns wenn wir jetzt hier
russland massiv schaden und jetzt schon
aufzudecken
willkommen schön sonntag aus köln schön
ist nicht ganz so klar positioniert wie
einem friedensvertrag besiegeln kann ich
militärisch muss mir auch mal sagen und
zurückgeschraubt es geht jetzt um den
ich bisher immer höhere ist das
wir nicht direkt liefern wollten sondern
phoenix und im radio auf wdr 5 die spd
eigentlich das treffen was vor sei aber
bis zur verpachtung ideen das sind alles
na ja das problem ist ja dass
unmittelbar in den nächsten wochen nicht
worden keine einzige der politische
musste sich ausziehen und dann haben sie
die ampel sei sehr geschlossen hier ist
eine gewisse verzerrung in dieser
hat begonnen nach dem prager frühling
herren roth von der spd deutlich andere
bestände an sowjet panzern in nato
also nächste schritt zu dem er quasi
rolle spielen jetzt auch mit zwei
gut wir gehen hat da war noch die zweite
tun als ob wir die ukraine ukraine
denke das wäre ein halbwegs
hier nur der vollständigkeit halber
natürlich gefordert wird einfach dass
dazu braucht man weltweit partner ist
warum sollten wir jetzt wieder in den in
die hauptlast dieser sanktionen trägt
don was und es geht um diese landbrücke
weil slowenien sowjetische panzer
dass sie dabei sind heute beim
gesagt hat nämlich die tatsache dass
in den krieg hineingezogen werden weil
deutschland permanent hinter der kurve
bild was sich nach außen ergibt ist
landtagswahlen vor der brust und ich
themen über die müssen dann insbesondere
sagen hat mit zur überwindung der
die grünen aber im moment ist was die
nach dem mann niedergeschlagen wurde und
russland seine truppen zurückzieht und
wille war acht wochen lang nicht da
realistischer weg aber ich bin überhaupt
presseclub da die im osten der ukraine
konzentration der debatte auf die spd
es geschafft aber sie haben gesagt am
russland und der krieg wohin führt stolz
ja erkennbar der versuch offen zu legen
retten wollen und sie in wirklichkeit im
position oder andere position vertreten
zur krim wenn er das erreicht hatten es
sowjetischer bauart hat mit denen die
depots aufgebraucht werden und dann wird
das ist eine ganz wichtige rolle spielen
deutschland wir sind seit 2014 der
einfach verteilt ich glaube auch dass da
freiwillig in die runde geben bevor wir
die ukraine mit den russen sprechen habe
geschoben werden muss also er hat jetzt
ist also ich würde ihnen zustimmen dass
ende war es wirklich nur glück und
jetzt live aus köln der presseclub mit
was passiert wenn putin jetzt diese
klar war okay da wird jetzt niemand mehr
die logik verfallen und sagen ja die
deutschland endlich ein landwirt das
dass sie es möglicherweise doch nicht
stich lassen das ist schäbig
teilung europas beigetragen
hätte es diesen druck nicht gegeben bin
ja in berlin spricht man man muss es so
ukraine was anfangen können und nicht
tobt die russische großoffensive und
das ist eigentlich denkbar weg ist das
waffenlieferung angeht
das ist das thema unserer runde hort die
man sich überlegen was man machen will
diese bereitschaft bei putin erkenne ich
zum nächsten anrufer kommen dieser krieg
noch in der argumentation einfach ist
gibt es liegt natürlich noch mal daran
gibt doch einen termin zu dem was
glaube tatsächlich dass ich kann scholz
das gesamtpaket wie es jetzt steht
was meine vermutung ist dass da noch ein
nicht nur ökonomisch sondern auch
kriegsziele die ein hoher militär
nicht militärexperte genug jetzt zu
ukraine hatte keine chance ich denke man
und übrigens
wichtigste und größte geldgeber der
wenn man weiter oder wenn man schwere
ich glaube es geht nicht ohne wählen der
genau das hat er doch in dieser woche
dass die spd jetzt am entscheidenden
raus brechen aus diesem osten dann hat
vermutlich erreichen will das ist der
jamaika
im presseclub und jetzt sind sie dran
keinen großartigen qualitativen
mit unserem modernen waffen wie
hässlich sagen von der troika der
auch öfter schon mal also jede waffe die
ich überzeugt wäre keine waffe mehr
ein bundeskanzler argumentiert ja auch
bringt weiter zerstörung und kaum
geopolitisch denken bewährten seit
ein stück weit verstehen er hat jetzt
das stand handgeschrieben drauf kinder
sagen welche schritte führen dahin wie
bisschen wasser den bach runter fließt
realistisch naja den waffenstillstand
1982 vor 40 jahren ist helmut schmidt
ukraine ist ich finde es einfach
hebel sitzt und den kanzler stellt und
im moment nicht und ich kann mir auch
formuliert hat tatsächlich umsetzen kann
mit ihren fragen an meine gäste und wir
artillerie von der sie sprechen das ist
allein drei mal gesagt zweimal
auf jeden fall die sinnvolle option als
neunte mai dieser jahrestag des sieges
gesagt in dem interview es gebe eine
muss genau so optimistisch darauf
angekommen
man wolle man dürfe keinen nationalen
entsprechende begleitung von dankt herrn
enttäuschten das sind drei politiker die
unterschied macht zumindest zu dem was
waffen liefern will neue panzer zu bauen
wer gibt die garantie dass er auch in
vorstellbares menschliches leid ins land
jahren schüttelt man den kopf über uns
unredlich so zu tun als würde
vorstellen dass es der westen dann
deutschland verlässt wird ja von scholz
mindestens einmal zuletzt im interview
der krieg dauert nun zwei monate schon
und dass man da noch miteinander reden
lange dauert das ist glaube ich auch
auch noch den bundespräsidenten der
artillerie aus den usa aus kanada die
man die ostpolitik begonnen und die aus
gross war wir sind am ende auch unsere
andere europäische länder mit einer
alleingang machen sie haben die nato
und die ukraine gezwungen ist sich damit
gehen zunächst nach meerbusch dort ist
entschuldigung bin ich widerspreche aber
über das faschistische deutschland
stellt man durch waffen her also je
blicken wir wie am anfang
wird also ich möchte mich da nicht
zudem auch noch lange jahre über zwei
mit dem spiegel sagte
lange tradition der verleumderischen
abgesehen hat mir geht es durch den
absehbarer zeit bei waffenlieferungen zu
und hierzulande regiert ein kanzler der
alle berechtigte hoffnung hatten in der
die ampel
deutschland da irgendwie in der
schwierig fände nach dem was jetzt alles
in warschau in paris in london und in
dauert ein paar jahre also sprich man
zurückgetreten nach dem misstrauensvotum
politik besteht darin ja vor allen
schwierig die kraft der russischen
presseclub nachgefragt wurden da
vergleichbar großen volkswirtschaft
wir gar nicht mehr haben die
angesprochen die nato hat angekündigt
zufrieden zu geben dann haben wir rein
wie steht es um die widerstandskraft im
das ist überhaupt nicht meine
wir wollen helfen er sagte wir dürfen
festlegen wie diese abstimmung ausgeht
ende ist hat der maler gewalt gibt es
bundessicherheitsrat und
laut einem russischen generalmajor herr
hans meyer am telefon herr meier seien
dann hat er zumindest mal etwas erreicht
nachdem wieviel panzer jetzt geliefert
machen frankreich italien die amerikaner
panzerhaubitze 2000 jetzt nochmal
legislaturperioden von angela merkel der
dingen dass man die einflusssphären ganz
irgendwie sagte ist von in der
bundesregierung gefasst zu werden das
angekommen ich danke ihnen liebe
wahrnehmung im gegenteil wenn sie ich
40 jahre sind vergangen in diesen 40
zwar eine zeitenwende angekündigt hat
nicht kriegspartei wir werden es darf
washington ganz so stellt sich der
darstellung der spd ost politik das
dass jetzt auch schwerere waffen
gesamte ost genau wie gesamt ausland
wäre dann vermutlich auch wieder
streitkräfte einzuschätzen also wie
irgend eine garantie kann man überhaupt
den widerstandsgeist der ukraine was
passiert ist einfach mit dem gleichen
schuldig also ich da nicht dass es jetzt
komfortzone sitzen das finde ich
aber sozusagen jedes mal gibt es einen
sind da viel weiter vorne die balken
militaristisch zu werden kann im moment
kolleginnen liebe kollegen für die
sie gegrüßt willkommen in unserer runde
geliefert werden an die ukraine es gibt
werden wie viele waffen zur verfügung
klar auf teilt dass man sagt ddr gehört
sind sie nicht geworden da spielen auch
zurückgeworfen darauf alte panzer
ich bin mal gespannt ob der eintrag
außenminister war von daher ist es auch
keinen atomkrieg geben und wir müssen
schrotthofer will russland die volle
irgendetwas sagen wann dieser krieg ein
was er glaubt vorzeigen zu können und
aber zunehmend als halbherziger zauderer
brücke zur im plus
lange das geht
beantwortung der fragen unserer zuhörer
gestellt werden wird die ukraine an
schlichtweg unredlich und ich sehe mich
kanzler am 27 februar hin und sagt jetzt
glaube sogar ein magazin als wir im haus
jahren hat die cdu 33 jahre lang den
viele enttäuschungen aber wenn sie sagen
sind wir weiter vorne vereinigen
nicht ganz unberechtigt dass wir jetzt
und ihre anmerkung zu unserer diskussion
denken sie auch über uns deutsche
in der ukraine gar niemand dienen dh sie
unseren bündnisverpflichtungen einhalten
wirklich kommt ich hatte das gefühl dass
russischen präsidenten weiter zu
aufzumöbeln das geht auch eine weile das
würde ich so nicht teilen aber natürlich
weiß ich nicht ich finde es ist aber
einen koalitionsbruch geben wird ich
dann glaube ich öffnet sich ein
kontrolle über die süd ukraine
verhältnis sowie wie viel
und zuschauer zuhörerinnen und
in austin das gehört in austin das
so viel darüber sprechen aber auch die
ende finden wird traut sich jemand eine
dieses leid der menschen dann muss das
hat jetzt das dümmste eine liste
antrag den wird der wird aber nicht vom
also bist also moldawien ein land mit
auch etliche bündnispartner die bereits
machen wir es anders wir haben es
einen punkt kommen an dem es leicht eine
er mehr als das jetzt im bild am sonntag
dasteht und innenpolitisch unter druck
arbeiten
dass die können nicht alles weggeben was
glaube die das verantwortungsgefühl bei
schauen wir da im moment tatsächlich
koalitionsbruch ich sehe nicht dass es
wirtschaftskraft sie haben aber vor
bitte der örtlichen dank der sich in die
kanzler oder die kanzlerin gestellt das
begrenztes zeitfenster dass man für
gehört den westen
rolle von angela merkel und der ihrer
zuschauerin das war der presseclub
ja wirklich noch mal sagen zu sehen wir
einschließlich eines land korridors zur
kapiert es da geht nicht nur um billiges
na ja offensichtlich jegliches vertrauen
fast ein bisschen defätistisch zu sagen
veröffentlicht welche länder inzwischen
prognose
interview schon fast ein bisschen wieder
sehr einseitig drauf und auch nicht ganz
wäre eine sache das sagen uns auch
schwerere waffen liefern pro bitzen viel
gerät auch aus den eigenen reihen seiner
ich habe mit vielen ukrainerinnen und
kanzler irgendwie vorbereitet sondern
wir hätten würden wir es dann haben hier
die spd das ist der kern aus politik die
dem wir auch jetzt neuerdings auch
können natürlich sagen es muss alles
eigenes immer noch so groß und lindner
für sie akzeptable
nur die putin darf nicht siegen also mir
nachgefragt auf phoenix und auf wdr5
sind erschüttert und bedrückt
einigen ist es auch viel zu langsam und
eingeholt hat also wenn bis dahin keine
ein einsamer nicht alles haben wir nicht
auch nur ansatzweise unter den
gas und und billige autos sondern jetzt
des westens enttäuscht hat natürlich
welche waffen in die ukraine geliefert
diplomatie nutzen muss ein inzwischen
minister die sie auch genannt haben muss
heißt diese ostpolitik von der helmut
sendung kann
krim und nach transnistrien
gebietsverluste gibt weil ich glaube die
altgediente generale generale ade dann
wieder stärker verbündet sind das ist
wir sehen ja dass in diesem krieg zeit
ukrainer hier gesprochen wir hatten erst
zu unrecht ich glaube es ist sehr sehr
komplexe fragen werden dadurch nicht
ampel koalition weil er bei den
dann müssen dann bestimmte leute hinter
man natürlich auch noch mal genau
können wir deutlich soll das denn noch
viel schneller und viel mehr aber es ist
normal man das was frau sauerbrei
relevanten die koalition tragenden
schwerer geht es jetzt nicht die
haben da liegt deutschland im oberen
fehlt tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen
hat jetzt auch noch mal sehr wohlwollend
anschauen ich glaube auch in der cdu gab
angenehmen sonntag die noch machen sie
sehr umstritten sozialdemokrat frau sie
wichtig noch einmal herauszustellen
ein entscheidender faktor ist also die
spd beruft sich jetzt auf die ostpolitik
sagen was soll er denn tun er soll das
die wir jetzt avisieren die russland
vor kurzem noch wir sind mit einem
lieferung erkennbar sind dann machen wir
kohl dann übrigens sehr stark profitiert
und ich glaube das ist auch
amerikaner ganz viele andere auch also
meine auffassung dazu ist dass es eine
geschafft hat und gibt das in die runde
einfacher ich will gar nicht der
die welt hinter den statements des
waffenlieferungen bremst und taktiert
dann eine rumpf ukraine die kein
nicht so einfach und was das
politikern und politikerinnen einen
mittelfeld tatsächlich wenn man die die
welche rolle geld schröder frank walter
müsste man dann halt jetzt anfangen um
deutschen auto hier ein pappschild da
werden wir zu einer
den kulissen mit der mit der industrie
es gut und schuss
in der situation die überhaupt nicht mit
tun was er sagt aber er tut es nicht
jetzt avisiert hatte nicht akzeptabel
lieferung schwerer waffen jetzt hier das
es einfach eine sträfliche
stehen da an der front und versuchen
hat was uns allen als deutsches volk
teile hier unwohlsein mit diesem
geäußert auf dem parteitag über herrn
wollte hat dazu in der new york times
wenn man diese tage die ampelkoalition
in absehbarer zeit so etwas wie eine
insofern sehe ich zumindest jetzt diesen
künstler mehr hatte ihre wichtigsten
oder zumindest seine politik nur
deutschen kanzlers zu sagen ja wir
geopolitisch verantwortlichen macht und
entscheidende ist ein kanzler und ich
das und wir haben ja jetzt schon die
für die ukraine unter den bedingungen
steinmeier habe auch sigmar gabriel beim
vernachlässigung
hybris innerhalb der journalisten und
dissens gibt über diese vier punkte die
so weit kommen bis der antrag
wort reden aber sie haben den faktor
zahl auch die qualität der waffen
stand drauf
die dann sozusagen in ein paar monaten
jetzt auch im don was sich zu
den 70er jahren zu vergleichen ist
wollen keine helfen diesen krieg zu
helfen verliert die all das was im
geäußert putin wolle den krieg beenden
nutzt aber diese ostpolitik ist ja
scholz wieder von dem inneren geländer
geopolitischer fragen zu gunsten von
verhandlungslösung überhaupt denkbar ich
nationalen alleingang nicht mehr
die unterschiedlichen stimmen aus fdp
wird sie weiter kämpfen und auch weiter
vorberichte das ist zum ringtausch
schreibtischtäter berater tun was
minimalistisch erklärt und kommuniziert
es sind unsere bomben und wenn man
verteidigen und die deutschen denken
dass die argumente wechseln mal ist es
zeit erwähnt und die forderung nach
ich aufgezeigt habe
einstiegen vor seitenwände genau ist
bereit zu haben wenn man sie dann eben
geliefert wurden betrachtet
gewinnen wir sind eben auf eurer seite
inneren des landes hat überhaupt nicht
sondern wie in mit dem zweiten weltkrieg
eingereicht wird bei der bundesregierung
begründet dazu passt ein eintrag bei
glaube jeder der verantwortung hat in
kommen könnte vielleicht lassen sie es
journalistinnen in deutschland gibt dass
neben unsere rolle war an der seite der
kämpfen müssen
fortgesetzt worden nämlich die
und der großen hochachtung verschießen
natürlich wir als journalisten manchmal
darüber nach revidieren listen bringen
grünen
geheimhaltung insbesondere frau
handelsfragen das haben wir auch nicht
es ist eben was ich ja nicht bestritten
will das ergänzen um einen eintrag den
um die bundesregierung unter druck zu
schweren waffen schuldiger einfach
mehr exportieren kann das ist ein
das war altkanzler gerhard schröder
unschuldige also wollte ich wollte es ja
sozialdemokratie zur frage der
in die ukraine wo möglich schicken
diesem land muss im auge haben dass
twitter von johannes sachse den möchte
länger mit den menschen hier spricht die
ich glaube es ist vielleicht auch das
kanzler gesprochen ich glaube nicht dass
vorstellung dass wir einen status quo
dann auch einfach wenn bis dahin
nichts was man eben so anzusetzen ist
haben und sobald ich dann
und wir helfen euch dabei auch wenn es
nur bei russland und 19 2 gesehen das
sie im grunde tagesaktuell über
zu vergleichen ist und danach wo man
ukraine und was diese acht wochen
begründet sich aus letzten beiden jahren
mehrere listen in umlauf streichen
lamprecht dann ist es wir haben nichts
setzen und dann
möchte ein neues ist helmut fürst am
klarheit herrscht ich glaube auch nicht
russland dass diese ganze strecke
waffenlieferungen hört wenn man das
oder die rücksicht vor eigenen genossen
wir im netz gefunden haben wir streamen
zeigt denn putin
sagen natürlich auch dass sie dankbar
haben wir auch gesehen weil china und
russland in der lage ist zu eskalieren
anerkennen müssen um ihn überwinden zu
was passiert wäre ohne diesen einen ich
es zum bruch komplett ich sehe die
ich ihnen noch mal
noch gar nicht weiß was ist der westen
unter diesem druck macht dann stolz sein
uns selber was kostet es ist zieht sich
eigentlich geheim zu haltende
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
die bundeswehr kann gar nichts abgeben
passiert ist ist dass sich gar nichts
wieder sachen runter verhandeln mit der
lief im don was jetzt stattfindet ist
reflektiert was wir gerade diskutiert
diese sendung ja auch und sie können
ich danke denn wir sind am ende der
sind dass deutschland so viele
die trotz seitenwände einer verfehlten
besetzt und eben auch bis zu diesen
problem dass die weitere strategische
vor ort see oder berichte über das leid
der frage wie sich das huawei hier die
würde ich sagen machen wir da reicht
unterschiede vor allen dingen in der
dass es dann zu einem koalitionsbruch im
was ist der osten jetzt können wir sagen
dann ist es die ukraine kann damit nicht
wie er nicht es sei denn wir wollen
schrotthofer als gerade angesprochen
telefon seien sie gegrüßt
liebe zuschauer ihre fragen an unsere
können wenn wir einen fehler gemacht
entgegenhalten sozusagen
geflüchtete aufnehmen dass deutschland
glaube das werden sie aber nicht in die
haben gibt es überhaupt so etwas wie
informationen informiert werden müssten
industrie sagen dann wird liefern
wichtigen schlüssel land moldawien dass
durch die einträge im netz immer wieder
okay wir zählen die ukraine jetzt zum
perspektive im kanzleramt selber noch
geändert hat und alle und das die ganze
auch ab von irgendwas herr scholz sagt
sendung angelangt danke für die
allerdings das ist ein ganz anderes
russlandpolitik nachtrauern die spd
umgehen stichwort wurde eben auch gerade
nächsten trippelschritt das also führung
einschätzung wie drängend das problem
haben lassen sie mich das noch sagen ja
der menschen sehe ist mir natürlich
riskieren einen dritten weltkrieg also
auch geld gibt aber sie sagen auch dass
gegenwart ist wie sie es darstellen der
montag ich hätte natürlich 100 fragen
5g netzwerke mit ausbau noch da musst du
der schreibt warum sollte man annehmen
vielleicht doch unsere leopard stellen
ich auch bedroht fühlt mit einer zone
osten und dann machen wir entspannungs
eine geschlossenheit der ampel und
engagierte und lebhafte diskussionen
ein gedanke der unser publikum offenbar
dabei auch unwohl ich glaube am ende es
ist also
wir haben einen fehler haben wir die
plenarsaal kommen würde ich habe das
und wenn man das vielleicht mal im
welt weiterhin den kopf schüttelt über
des widerstands und der westlichen
runde hier auch dort stellen und wir
nicht so ganz klar ist also wir hatten
sieht anders aus ja das ist sie
der herr geißler für ein klassisches
dann erst fest dass gar keine munition
territorium als der kampf um die
bundeskanzler ich möchte wirklich nicht
genannt marder oder leopold
dass liebe zuschauer war der presseclub
russland und der krieg wohin führt
wenn das kann man so leichthin sagen
natürlich man steht die das kanzleramt
in diesem krieg halten wir jetzt gerade
politik mit mit osteuropa wo die ukraine
frischen frage weil er sich auch
beschäftigt nämlich ob waffenlieferungen
stringenz in der reaktion auf dem man
internationalen kontext auch ein
die regierung von angela merkel zum
dass putin überhaupt einen unterschied
reaktionen inzwischen tatsächlich so
und anmerkungen aber ich möchte mich
mehr dafür da ist also das ist doch ein
in seiner haut stecken hat ja eine
ja gelegenheit jetzt mit jens büttner zu
die ohnehin schon um stärker rechtlich
gefühl dass dann vielleicht die spd
noch kommen stört euch doch nicht wir
scholz das ist unser thema heute ihren
gestellt hat was ist denn heute der
deutschland achters ist ich glaube es
residenz schnell geeignete es für panzer
ist die ukraine die entscheidet auch
beispiel ist
eigentlich diesen krieg verlängern oder
ihrem ersten wir freuen uns wenn sie in
macht zwischen denen die geliefert haben
bisschen einbetten wollen der berufs
unsere köpfe hin und ihr kommt aus ihrer
jagen getragen werden von den
t-72 darauf sind sie geschult
sozusagen das ist zum wiederholten
werden die in der sendung auch
etwas wie eine tendenz zu einer
großes vor sich hin vegetieren in einer
geschenke noch eine kernfrage an die
umstritten ist die weiterhin offiziell
sagt ist und die außenstehenden fordern
status quo das ist ja der unterschied
presseclub darüber wollen wir
berücksichtigen dort wird insbesondere
die
machen aber wenn man gerade festgestellt
müssen jetzt mal richtig an aber das
wann dieser krieg zu ende ist es ist ein
muss es ja so nennen russischen überfall
amerikanern die gesagt haben wir
gegen antrag einbringen würde hinter dem
ist schlichtweg falsch wir müssen nicht
komfortzone nicht raus es gibt kein
sowjetisches kriegsmaterial also die
den sozialen netzwerken weiter mit uns
dann dazu gehört kann man machen ich
kanzler hat sehr sehr große erwartungen
auf den herr geiger fünfter punkt im
unglaubliche verantwortung im moment
so moldawien gehört wo aber auch russen
und denen die die lieferung mit geld
diskutieren und das sind meine gäste
an einen punkt führen können wo die
lieferung von waffen sollte eigentlich
dass das was deutschland mittlerweile in
in einer ebene werden sie typische
verhandlungslösung das wurde immer
risiko ist ungeheuer groß und ehrlich
zentralen außenpolitischen berater im
brauchen mehr sicherheitsgarantien
situation in der zeit ein entscheidender
anwesen ist es nicht richtig zu sagen
auf die ukraine
sozusagen die diskussion von fleisch
kalten krieg waren die grenzen auch
geweckt mit seiner seiner ruck rede mit
ist die lieferung schwerer waffen die
argumente wechseln ja dann ist die sorge
denn einerseits jahr wollen wir den
sowohl als auch im moment mehr ihr müsst
sich dann auch wieder alle versammeln
diskutieren mögen etwa beim presseclub
oder ringtausch das ist er aktuell in
panzerschlachten voraussichtlich sehen
souveränes land letztlich muss die
russische soldaten in transnistrien
anna sauerbrey sie ist außenpolitische
würde sagen wir sollten eher dafür
chance für eine verhandlungslösung
gestellt wie soll man denn ernsthaft ich
bei den unternehmen das auch die waren
faktor ist und natürlich sehr stimmig
oder im rio würde jetzt nicht sagen ist
also im moment so sagen im moment
nicht so wie die völker sie in
könnte also könnte man bestimmt noch was
wieder in manche seiner aktion hinein
die ukraine geliefert hat und zwar im
kanzleramt langjähriger leiter von musik
ohne kenntnis der öffentlichkeit
gesagt ich bin froh dass ich es
schon lange stationiert sind und die
um den atomkrieg
menschen in der ukraine helfen wollen
jetzt vermutlich über den ringtausch
aber was
der debatte ermöglichen unsere
diesen 100 milliarden er ist sehr gelobt
selbstbestimmung wollten aber sie waren
wächst ich nehme pars pro toto einen
euch schon entscheiden die welt muss
account auf twitter hier geht es jetzt
bevölkerung in die regierung entscheiden
dass man ganz auf verschiedenen
an oberster stelle steht er die aussage
völlig zu die erklärung warum es nicht
persönlich nicht zu tragen habe aber das
auch kaum wird es wird eingelöst ich
selben zeitraum wie alle anderen
machen damit es eben nicht ganz so blöd
sorgen dass die ukraine zum westen
der um keine helfen andererseits ist
koordinatorin der wochenzeitung die zeit
auf diesem auge total blind lange jahre
sich entscheiden und auch deutschland
eindeutig ja im moment haben wir einen
verlieren aber ich halte dass wir nichts
wie viel leid sind wir bereit in kauf zu
erfolgen weil wenn man sich im krieg
ernsthafte diplomatische verhandlungen
weiter mit dem europamagazin auch da
steuern wir eindeutig auf den
geheimnis also für mich ist es jetzt
was trägt man nun wirklich das ist ja
entscheidung von putin abhängig zu
ungefähr dem entspricht sie sagten
worden im ausland man hat das gewertet
geschaffen wir haben ein text über ihn
verbietet mir auch so leichthin über
aussieht wird die spd fraktion
passiert die variieren ständig also
vielleicht dann als nächstes erobern mit
antrag auf twitter wie kann am ende eine
geht es um die ukraine aber auch um die
täten und es ist falsch dass die ganzen
auch klar gestellt worden wir wollen und
seid ihr für uns oder seid ihr gegen uns
krieg zwischen einem land das von einem
die ob er schon mal gemacht hat putin da
lang also völlig d'accord und ich glaube
gehört und die mauer und das ist ja das
durchführen wenn eine seite offenbar
koalitionsbruch zu auf einen
befindet der gegner mithört
genau also sozusagen also ich hab mir
machen ist unfug hat johannes achse
sabine siebold arbeitet für den
und so frisst sich das dann weiter in
nehmen um wie viel territorium zu
als eine abkehr von russland politik
noch nicht offensichtlich erkennbar
politische entscheidungsträger zu
sauerbrey was andere länder unserer
das tempo unterschiedlich bewertet also
etwas was die öffentlichkeit umtreibt
militärische lösung aussehen die frieden
entweder ich sage na gut ich möchte
geschrieben wo wir auch die gelegenheit
nachbarn überfallen wurde und die
heutige entscheidung bei der
geschlossen sind das ist eine gute frage
wirklich weh tun zu wenig
diese debatte wird auch noch kommen
dürfen nicht kriegspartei werden und
vielen dank silke dittrich nach nico und
koalitionsbruch sagen sie wenn man wenn
englischen dienst der nachrichtenagentur
den sagen immer weiter in den naturraum
was ist wie wir eklig ist diese
recht
ziel entgegen seiner rede im bundestag
verteidigen
nicht an verhandlungen interessiert ist
daher ist es für mich eigentlich eine
treffen und zu reden wie es im moment
nicht besiegen
vielleicht äußert sich frau merkel ja
hatten mit ihm zu sprechen ich und zwei
präsidentschaftswahl in frankreich im
und stabilität bringt wer weiß die
die anderen wollen es einfach schneller
dieses ausland lang als falsch
größe und leistungsfähigkeit einer so
grenzen sind nicht ein was furchtbar ist
diese anrufer kommt aus cuxhaven steffen
darüber
drittens wir bewegen uns im kontext der
gezahlt gesagt hat bauen sie nicht die
kommunikation wie transparent ist wäre
gesagt sie misstrauen unseren recherchen
ich glaube das wird diese woche auch
rein weil da gibt es auch eine debatte
irgendwann mal gespannt wir gehen in die
die frage ist der berichtigung ist ein
er schlägt offenbar auch weiter direkte
kollegen und wir hatten das gefühl ist
oft der fall ist sie haben die
reuters in deren brüsseler büro klaus
haben und stolz ist sehr abwägend sehr
sind die europäer sind die usa längst
man die position wenn man sich die
dem muss ich eigentlich alles
antwort
aus meiner sicht schon aber so sagen ich
presseclub nachgefragt gibt's wie immer
ich will diese eindrücke gleich in
recht doch nur das grüne liste dass wir
was furchtbar ist eine totale
kritisiert hat und ich merke in
diskutieren wir und da gibt es den
verhandelt von daher ist es eine
das ist ein schwerwiegender vorwurf den
panzerhaubitze 2000 angesprochen
der nato vielleicht beizutreten jetzt
völlig falsche herangehensweise
mauer im westen der ukraine sondern im
position anschaut wenn man es gibt doch
ich glaube
nato-partner und all das tut man
unsere runde geben frau sauerbrei
jetzt auf phoenix und im radio auf wdr5
furchtbares dilemma in dem wir uns
katastrophe auf welcher basis frage ist
ich mein so rein politisch strategisch
kriegspartei sie sind teil dieses
spannende woche wir hatten jetzt den
unterordnen alles natürlich eigentlich
schon ganz klar gesagt wird die aus
morgen aus der angucken ehrlich gesagt
dissens und das ist im presseclub auch
deutschland hat das waffensystem
reinen ist am telefon erreichen seien
schöne stadt trier mechthild gottes ist
doch also es ist ja nicht so einfach ist
muss ich im namen der welt zurückweisen
osten und die spd meine in meiner wahren
gesprächen einfach dass da jetzt eine
schrotthofer ist herausgeber der neuen
dass in dieser asymmetrischen
gar keine unterschiedlichen positionen
befinden ich finde diese militärische
aufruf zur geschlossenheit von muetze
ständig zu verlangen dass man sie möchte
verhandlungen zum beispiel mit präsident
ungeschickt in der kommunikation und das
deswegen ist es nicht so einfach zu
wie kann man jetzt dagegen vorgehen und
richtig so denn wir wollen ja kontrovers
krieges sie liefern waffen sie beraten
scheint plötzlich kein atom treck so und
betrachtet muss er natürlich
entscheidet sich in diesen tagen das
ich finde wenn ich zu diesem alle sagen
grundschutz wie kommen ich begrüße sie
und die holländer haben auch gerade
ernüchterung kommt dass man einfach
ja wir haben sehr gute quellen von
unterschiedlich position also diese
ja damit nicht auf und von daher denke
nicht der sich trotz ja eigentlich
verschiedene
selensky aus und also wir werden jetzt
sie gegrüßt
westfälischen zeitung und klaus geiger
ärgert die anderen jetzt einfach
diskutieren und jetzt gehen wir zu
am telefon frau gottes herzlich
sagen
logik sondern diesmal auch sehr
politik wie wir sie kannten es vorbei
wann welche lieferung genau passiert ist
sind mit militärberatern vor ort sind
versucht sie im westen zu bauen und dann
schicksal der ukraine ja ja also ich
das ist doch ein unterschied sich aus
jetzt sich erwartet hat dass der
was immer ihr wollt wir liefern sondern
beschlossen genau dieses waffensystem in
wahnsinnig weil natürlich das ganze
konstellation wo einer im prinzip ist
es geht nicht darum dass die
abweichender pazifistischer position
mehreren seiten mehrere quellen wissen
verschiedene interessen gleichzeitig
lassen wir uns nicht den popanz von
leitet das außenpolitische ressort der
tobias wirtz nach münchen
ich muss dann vielleicht doch ein
denn es gibt auch dieses russland nicht
koalition tut mir leid wenn sie mich
verführerisch weil auch ich auch glaube
willkommen in unserer runde und nun sind
bundesrepublik oder irgendwer ist
politischen willen lieferte wie die usa
ampel projekten mit seiner kommunikation
handlungen kommen dass da einfach ein
die von informationen die entscheidend
die ukraine zu ihm rein und ihre
moskau aufbinden nämlich mit dieser
exakt was geliefert wurde exakt das
bedienen also einerseits natürlich
keine seiner handlungen präsident die
sehr deutlich hinter den kanzler
zum 2 die zeit selbst wenn wir jetzt
bisschen offensiver kommunizieren auch
zudem gerade genannten atomwaffen
man muss in jedem einzelfall prüfen was
glaube man kann es nicht anders sagen
mehr von dem wir glaubten dass es da ist
sind um russische kriegsziele angreifen
bisschen mehr hinterherkommt und das
wir gespannt auf ihren beitrag
welt seien sie alle herzlich willkommen
geschweige denn irgendeine partei jetzt
es gibt ganz viele völkerrechtler die
gegenüber den bündnispartnern
großbritannien wie polen oder ob ich zu
dann wieder irgendwie für für
gemeinsam baden geht und ich kann von
artillerie aufgelöst haben und die
will sie mit und dann kann man schon
gestellt hat es wird ja auch noch mal
dieser krieg ist darauf angelegt die
geben wir in den faktencheck aber frau
in die weitere zucht aber da stellt sich
mit dem wir diese ost politik machen
ich denke
verantwortung zeigen dann gibt es einen
voreingenommen halten aber man muss soll
wirklich darauf hindeuten dass er akut
eskalieren kann unter anderem nicht ist
wenn sie diese bilder sehen aus der
festlegt was von der eu keine übrig
eskalation die definition die noch von
ausbildung in diesen gruppen system
zu können und dann zu sagen na gut wir
sagen kriegspartei wird man indem man
eine frage will ich gern noch mal in die
kann man tun um diesen bedingungen die
und zunächst wollen wir in die ukraine
daher verstehen das ist jetzt bei der
ukraine als staat zu vernichten und ist
eine eigene aussprache in der
können aber so eine richtige alternative
großen teil der deutschen öffentlichkeit
jeder einzelnen lieferung getragen
diese ganzen waffen liefern er von den
erlebt man nicht und da macht sich
verhandeln ja
sauerbrei
ich bin
gesamte runde geben das eine ist wir
erfolgt in deutschland genau aber das
eine verhandlungslösung anstrebt ja ja
bleiben soll aber sie müssen doch in
ukraine von dieser zerstörung von dieser
die fakten zumindest mal zur kenntnis
soldaten irgendwo hinstellen nicht indem
fraktionssitzung der spd dazu geben es
genannt wurden gerecht zu werden
die genau das richtig findet sie auch
fdp und bei den grünen das dringende
blicken dort ist in nico nicht weit von
da scheint man sich auch noch so ein
per se keine militärische lösung geben
atomkrieg geschichte von herrn scholz
wenn man jetzt mal von dem was über die
werden muss und ob ich acht wochen lang
nehmen diese ampel koalition hat in
haben über die wechselnden begründungen
putin computing bedeutet ihren platz
abgesehen davon angesichts des traurigen
auch darauf angelegt viele ukraine zu
einer situation in der ein eine der
langsam schon ein bisschen in forschung
waffenlieferungen befürwortet die große
bedürfnis gibt darauf hinzuweisen dass
wollen nicht dass die nato damit
ist eine ausbildung von ukrainischen
bisschen heranzutasten also da gibt es
brutalität hat man ich glaube jeder
ich halte diese wahrnehmung für falsch
und die aspekte gesprochen
er waffen liefert und nach der lesart
gibt auch versuche so zusagen von seiten
halte ich persönlich für vorgeschoben er
aktuell entzündet sich die
kann die militärische unterstützung ist
vieren die neben ihnen sitzen verspricht
sabra und im frontverlauf entfernt meine
waffenlieferung hinaus schaut dann merkt
will das noch mal an sie weiter geht ja
solidarität weiterhin mit der ukraine
soldaten die ausgehen deutsch an einem
finden kann wir sagen auch gott auch
man wieder besser oder schlauer
vom ich lache wochen lang und sagen sie
töten auch zivilisten
des willy brandt haus so die debatte um
innenpolitische debatte auch innerhalb
zustand unserer bundeswehr gibt es auch
jetzt den begriff des cons trend der
reingezogen wird liefern deswegen keine
ist das ein klarer kurs oder
einer rasenden geschwindigkeit nicht nur
denken muss und hier steht also ein
und übrigens noch ist durch die
mir denn das dann innerhalb von sagen
man doch schon ich glaube das kann man
jetzt wichtig um zu verhindern dass die
macht dasselbe was alle kanzler vor ihm
und es geht jetzt darum da mit allen
darsteller weder wenn man auch noch das
der ampel koalition am streit um die
halbwegs normale mensch hat das
holländischen panzerhaubitze 2000 system
mir das ist das aufrichtig ist es in
größten armeen der welt ein land und
gerade der geschlossenheit der antike ja
gott keinen atomkrieg ein dritter
gar nicht mehr so sehr viel was wir
die internationale politik so ein
ist weder die nato noch irgendjemand
kollegin silke dietrich von dietrich wie
empfindet und dann gibt es natürlich
auch in den 90er jahren schon mal für
bisschen das angebot was man da
wir mal einem halben jahr ich bin
sagen wie schwer sich insbesondere die
kanzleramt in der hand hält in der
ostpolitik
gemacht haben erfolgs wieder der
vielleicht ist den man einfach nur
bedürfnis zurückzuschlagen mit allem was
abgeben können und was die ukrainer
bisschen zu kanalisieren in einer
ein
weltkrieg mit dieser armee kann er kann
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
ukraine schnell unter geht man muss das
doch sozusagen anderen nato-partner
aber auch einen guten teil der
wird die gleiche sein wie einem
ein mögliches verhältnis zu china
sozusagen das macht ja also die ring
mitteln dagegen zu halten sowie die
großzügig
anders im moment kriegspartei die andere
deutschen wirtschaft die mit sicherheit
zwar eindeutig aggressiv brutal
spd tut ihrer russlandpolitik neu zu
jahrzehntelanges diktum der deutschen
hat in erster linie mal den status quo
kommenden woche weg die union ja einen
verweigert sich der kanzler oder
eigenen arbeitsgruppe aber es wird ich
wirklich peinlich dass wir zwar eine
man hat und die russen in die flucht zu
nur das war ein koalitionsbruch sagen
deutschen also ich glaube das argument
stellt sich derzeit die lage angesichts
nämlich den slowenen zum ermöglichen
irgendeiner form
bevölkerung nicht aber auch dass ein
verwendet wurde also einerseits ein
der krieg beendet ist
korrespondentin das auch gesagt sind es
brauchen können auch die bundesrepublik
warum tut sich kanzler scholz und
kriegt die nato führen keinen
so brutal sagen und das beste frau sauer
jetzt schon im kanzleramt um macht und
sie tatsächlich in dem fall nicht die
eigentlich müsste es ja können
angemessen diesen leid dass sie auch
und statt sie waren überall dazwischen
teil dieses interviews im spiegel jetzt
außenpolitik abgeräumt nämlich überhaupt
überfallen hat müssen sie doch eine
täuschen die sind ja alles gut aber
antrag im parlament
sache ist natürlich wie putin das
der größeren großoffensive da was hören
schlagen ich glaube nur nüchtern
geht tatsächlich um die existenz des
habe noch mal ein bisschen nach gehört
panzer zu liefern auch das widerspricht
anerkannt das war neu das war ist eine
mindestmaß an wie ein austausch und
kommuniziert er nur nicht stringent was
definieren das ja auch nicht schlimm
riesige wirtschaftsmacht aber
offenbar auch die spd so schwer damit ja
hat bündnisverpflichtungen auch das hat
konventionellen die atomare gefahr ist
irgendwann sind wir auch voll gesagt die
dankeschön haben wir eine auffassung ist
märz hat scholz zu einer
perspektive haben wo das enden sollen
franzosen haben jetzt auch übrigens
schon sehr hart gestritten also gerade
tut und wie gesagt wenn der wiederaufbau
wenn eine politische partei sich
breiter stimme ich zu das beste was man
ist ein genau dieses spannungsverhältnis
waffen in krisengebiete zu liefern sie
staates und seiner bewohner herr geiger
genau auf diesen teil der bevölkerung
einschätzt beziehungsweise wie er darauf
sich doch vollkommen also entweder ich
der kanzler mehrfach in der
beklagen dass man in acht wochen quasi
betrachtet gibt es kein realistisches
sie von den menschen die die front
gespräch und gleichzeitig aber ein sehr
angekündigt ihre pizzen zu schicken aber
militärisch tatsächlich ans werk ich
schwertut beim wandel aber man kann ist
unter den außenpolitikern da kann ja
auch gezielt als die eben angst haben
war an aber das bedeutet ja suizid
panzer aufgebraucht und dann ist nichts
regierungserklärung aufgefordert aber
eigentlich die linie ist denn das sind
sage die nato solle nicht reingezogen
der großen historischen leistungen von
genau aber so sagen ich war ja noch gar
losgeht müssen wir dran außerdem
und diese perspektive kann nicht
sagen sie es mir sagen dass da jemand
dass dieser krieg noch jahre dauern wird
jetzt kurzfristig erreichen kann auch im
hat zugleich einen 100 milliarden etat
zurückliegenden woche gesagt diese
nicht gesprochen hat mit der ukraine
reagiert wenn er sagt er findet wir sind
starkes einhegen durch hat
die offensive russischer truppen in der
ja ja ja ja also
szenario das dahin führt es ist gelungen
auch wirklich völlig unterschiedliche
werden oder ich sage denn dann lassen
beobachten führende sozialdemokraten am
auch angekündigt dass er sonst einen
willy brandt übrigens gegen den
absoluten suizid und so verrückt halte
erlebt haben
brauchen wir gas also halt schön zurück
vor einer eskalation des krieges also
ja die eindrücke die sie grad schildern
militärisch sein das ist ja nur das was
interesse der menschen die da jetzt in
nicht dabei dass zumindest meine
wie wir recherchieren jetzt seit vielen
mehr da ich glaube wir müssen jetzt
bündnisverpflichtungen müssen wir
über waffen dass man eine liste mit
habe von der presse von presse die ich
danke schön herr meier bewusst nach
ukraine hält an kann das land auf dauer
meinungen aufeinander ag außenpolitik
kriegspartei und er reagiert
zumindest jetzt mal avisiert wenn die
das sieht man eigentlich immerhin
auch mit deutschen waffenlieferungen
auch die öffentlichkeit fragt sich ja
die zweite frage die cdu stellt sich hin
den luftschutzkeller locken ist dass man
diversifizierung von handelsbeziehungen
fehler eingeräumt selbst der
erfüllen
sie sagen will stellen sie mal vor sie
hier kommen sehr viele flüchtlinge an
abnahmegarantien geben damit die
wochen und wir haben keine antworten und
ich auch den verrückten dann tut ihn
konservativer damals dieser zeit den
hatte ihr vorhin schon gesagt ist es
umfangs die leute sagen ja wir freuen
einbringen wird wird das der moment der
lese unterschied durch auf reguläre zeit
meerbusch und da sie ja direkt
durch waffen aber das ist natürlich was
ist sowohl hersteller als auch daneben
leichten waffen die die anderen alle
welches argument ist denn jetzt valide
nicht diese installation wagen wird also
cdu den mitmacht um die bundeswehr und
liefern jetzt diese panzer alle panzer
bundespräsident auch frau schwesig die
entsprechend dann ist es eigentlich
liefern aber so richtig rein gezogen
schön entkräftet haben
nur eine ganze anzahl gemeinsam möchten
diesem angriff wirklich standhalten hat
wird sehr komplex dann wenn man in die
aus dem donnerstag tief und natürlich
wenn diese diese reduzierten kriegsziele
deutsche rüstung sagen sicherheit hat
wir bekommen sie auch von niemanden und
wahrheit für die ampel dazu fragt auch
status quo erstmal anzuerkennen mit dem
bin ich
die werden ja sozusagen täglich auch
live haben die panzer sind irgendwann
schon geliefert haben acht wochen keine
diese theoretische unterschied hin
werden als nato land wollen wir eben
angesprochen haben bitte
und tut so als hätten die letzten 16
details der waffensysteme geht was
michael roth und nils schmid und viele
die europäische verteidigung völlig neue
ganz engagierten und mutigen kampf der
dass also das ist natürlich von
schwer unter beschuss steht wegen ihrer
noch die aussage putin darf nicht gegen
das sozusagen als der krieg vorher
sie nicht werden schreiber für olaf
die ukraine eine realistische chance
wo das bundeskanzleramt auch jetzt
die ukraine weiß es selber auch nicht
also nicht facebook oder so was für ich
aus mario pohl gerade in den letzten
kaputt putin kann eskalieren wir können
jahre im ausland gelebt wir hatten einen
ja vielen dank herr meyer für die frage
scholz werden das habe ich jetzt alles
nicht in diesem krieg und natürlich
variiert die frage des erstens was ist
ziel ihn zu überwinden aber
einer unserer zuschauer im internet oder
beine zu stellen und sehr drittens
fällen verspottete was war ihre position
beendet ist
sicher ist ist dass olaf scholz keine
tatsächlich ja noch nicht wissen kann
langsam hat verliert man den überblick
von putin zunächst erreicht sind dann
verheimlicht hat das sind ist doch
tagen sind das sehr viel weniger
wollen wir auf jeden fall dass eine
klimastiftung der unterstützung von nord
was müssen wir tun dass putin nicht
verstanden dass das was er die letzten
russlands krieg zu stoppen ich denke ja
die panzer auch in deutschland
menschen in der ukraine
dieser dazwischen sind ich glaube das
was ist das für ein land mit dem wir zu
das ziel also was ist das was ist das
macht es einen unterschied eigentlich
innenminister seehofer und einen
interessierter seite sagt man ja das
große eskalation verhindert wird und
bei den waffenlieferungen und ich will
ständig wir sind nicht mehr in der lage
dass dieses erste kriegsziel putins die
sanktionen mit verabschiedet sie hat
menschen geworden aber wir konnten mit
waffe mehr geliefert hat als nebelkerzen
es nicht was machen wir dann eine
wahnsinn ich misstraue ihren
tun haben also wird putin da weiter eine
was landbrücke zur krim dass man dann
oder bzw die anmerkung ich bin da ganz
acht wochen gesagt hat der oder gemacht
sag ich doch an ihren status ja aber es
stream zwei diese seinerzeit gegründet
wirtschaftsminister altmaier wieso sind
aufgenommen werden aber ansonsten jemand
sind 33 so hein ist die nicht wissen
ziel vor allen dingen der spd an dieser
wird es den augen von putin
auch das muss ja immer wieder abholen
fliegt sagen das nicht sein schließlich
bei twitter genau gesagt werden fdp und
flugverbotszone stellen sie sich mal vor
einer jungen familie sprechen die
also das ist die gleiche frage die wir
wird schon noch mal eine aufgabe für die
einen flughafen ich kann zu verteidigen
da bin ich mir zu 100 prozent sicher
jetzt auch überhaupt nicht mit in die
rolle spielen wer wird nach ihm kommen
unterschiedlich beurteilt ob wir direkt
hat oder getrickst hat und wir haben
rechercheergebnissen um es offen zu
volle kontrolle über die ukraine der
viertels beschlossen sich möglichst
worum es geht ja aber die koalition
hat
und dann schießen nato-flugzeuge
versucht die situation einzufrieren und
wochenlang unter diesen bombenhagel in
aber trotzdem ist er eben in der
die ukraine gehen in den nächsten jahren
war nicht so dass willy brandt oder
bei ihnen ich finde das auch in
details gehen aber wenn man es mal
fraktionsspitze da die leute
die gasspeicher leer und wieso spricht
beschränken danke schön herr wüst und
sagen ein anderer ist das sehr viel in
wann tun sich tut sich die spd so schwer
nach all diesen recherchen und die frage
wie stabil wird das ganze sein wenn
grüne am donnerstag dem unionsantrag so
uns am 24 februar gestellt haben wo sehr
schnell unabhängig zu machen von
wollte auf einen langen krieg einstellen
gesehen ja getrickst hat auch in all
andere gesagt hätten so dass es jetzt
durchmarsch nach kiew nicht erreicht
enttäuscht dass das aber ist da kommen
etwa panzer waffen liefern oder über den
zusammenzuführen so doch nicht so
argumentation völlig unklar wie sie sehr
unterbricht dennis folgendes passiert
russische flugzeuge ab und dann sind wir
da keiner drüber dafür ist meine frage
liegt man so blöd sein wir sagen wir
dann tatsächlich über
mario pohl gelebt hat und die haben
militärischen konflikten
dieser krieg dann in teilen verloren
russischen gasimporten ich finde das
ihnen einen schönen tag und sauerbrei
geschlossen ist bild aber vielleicht
die westliche das ist die restliche welt
er denn kommt zustimmen was haben wir da
ist doch und ich da bin ich ja verlegt
wurde insofern hat er jedenfalls ist das
begeben putin irgendwie so dass ein
wir zu sehr speziell eine spezielle
die ukraine gegangen ist teils mit
verhandlungslösungen heil sondern sie
müssen was halten sie davon
scholz hat in seiner zeitenwende rede
den kurs zu korrigieren
grundsätzlich wichtig dass man
unseren recherchen entschuldigung da
wirklich schlimme dinge erzählt weil sie
im dritten weltkrieg das kann keiner
gut aufgezählt haben also die argumente
umweg von slowenien also ich glaube
danke schön herr einen schönen gruß nach
was sagen sie und ist ja ich mir ist es
geht ich will da gar nicht so hart sein
viele leute gesagt haben die ganz
bei ihnen mehr statt hofer
haben keine
und so wird es bleiben und darin
sicher ist die grünen stehen nicht da wo
geiger steht schlägt die stunde der
sind 4 ziemlich starke punkte die diese
sagen auch die ukraine sollte auf diese
meinen eigentlich dass mario pohl eine
stillschweigen über so etwas vereinbart
zu erwarten
wer möchte dann wird es einfach
öffentlicher ankündigung teils ohne und
mein eindruck und es gibt viele
flugzeuge die prägen das ist doch alles
wollen deswegen muss unser ziel sein
gesagt wir stellen uns auf die richtige
habe ich nicht eine aussage gehört wurde
bisschen mehr sein auch ein stück von
arrangieren wir uns und ehrlich gesagt
widersprechen sich auch teilweise und
cuxhaven und wer möchte herein antworten
ich glaube tatsächlich viele
gebiete dann verzichten das kann ich
moderne stadt jetzt haben sie da gelebt
diese argumentation die sie vorbringen
wahrheit ja ganz woanders man kann jetzt
anzeichen dazu seine kriegsziele
jedenfalls dass irgendwelche
der ukraine und und dann verhandeln wir
koalition hingekriegt hat und wenn sie
seite in der geschichte an die seite der
versuchen aber sind angesprochen worden
erstmals zumindest zu einem
besonders tolle realpolitiker waren nein
weil ich glaube es ist tatsächlich auch
nur wenn man dann bei der recherche
fast so wenig dieses putin darf nicht
mein eindruck ist dass wir im moment
völkerrechtlichen gutachten putin nicht
die spd steht und zwar geschlossen nicht
ich glaube auch nicht dass es vielleicht
was er stolz gesagt hat das ist doch
sich olaf scholz man hingestellt hat und
das ist der blick in die glaskugel naja
lesen eine rheinmetall tochter wolle 100
nicht sagen man wird dann es gibt ganz
nicht schuldig watt übertragen könnten
waffenstillstand zu kommen und dann
eine sehr schwierige situation der mann
das sind dann tatsächlich es ist eine
ukraine und liefern deswegen waffen dann
wie finde ich völlig schlüssig und das
wie in der steinzeit das dach war weg
eine ganze menge leisten auch das darf
kann sie natürlich nicht sie wird
nostalgische gefühle und auch zumindest
mal ist es mein mann will man sich die
siegen also natürlich also ich glaube es
und da geht es nicht um irgendwelche
beeindrucken werden sondern es geht
gesagt hat so so so so ist es das
dann nochmals ein bisschen auf zu machen
durch die presse gegangen wir haben nix
sagen der herr ist entschuldigung auch
jetzt eine neue strategie entwickeln
unterschiedliche ideen wie man in diesen
einzelnen leute da geht es um hardware
ist eine position die man haben kann
politische entscheidung wenn sie die
untergehen gegen diese übermacht die
unter dem druck von sanktionen
die haben im flur überleben müssen
darum ob wir faktisch ihn an den rand
da bin ich nicht überzeugt dass es da
strategisch valide ist zu sagen es
dazu dient das gar nichts geliefert wird
muss jetzt heißen die ukraine so zu
muss das eine frage die dazu passt auf
söhne vermutete name was die spd-basis
hat er eine lieferung ins schaufenster
man nicht vergessen diese sanktionen die
aber warum geht scholz nicht hin und
zeitlinie sehen klar wenn dieser krieg
gerade angesagt entschuldigen sie die
mader direkt an die ukraine liefern dazu
ganze ukraine geben ich habe im nahost-
dilemma da ganz aufrichtig gesagt ist es
gebieten folgen die gab es übrigens
unter dem druck internationaler
stärken dass sie wie wir feiern auch in
gestellt hat die sogar auf twitter
hatten kein wasser kein strom kein gas
ukraine hat sich und man muss dieses
und da sagt auch eine ein leeres
burghof weiter beide flügel der grünen
und dass das quasi nur eine trickserei
twitter wollte stellt die frau sibold
schon in den verträgen minsk 1 und 2 die
eine kakophonie gibt ich erlebe
zusammenarbeit zu versuchen eine
sagt dem deutschen ehrlich dass es so
einer niederlage drängen und das ist ja
angekündigt und danach bis acht wochen
politik aus politik ja was man oft
wort auch mal verwenden in einem
und ständig bomben und raketen dann
inspekteur aber die presse sagt scholz
der debatte gesagt haben an einem punkt
alle alle stehen woanders die union hat
ist und das ist so eindeutig in unseren
so und dass ich deswegen machen sie den
braucht es eine genehmigung des
heroischen kampf verteidigt hat kiew hat
und kann es eine politische lösung denn
ist dass man sagt okay wir haben mir ist
sind ja von beiden seiten nie wirklich
das was sie ausblenden abgesehen davon
regelung zu finden die zumindest fürs
kommt militärisch wo es eine akzeptable
vergisst ist ja die ostpolitik hat erst
lang nicht eine waffe ohne
haben sie sich getraut endlich aus der
mit putin überhaupt geben wenn putin
versagt das kann nicht sein
recherchen wie nichts anderes dann finde
bundessicherheitsrats dem steht faktisch
zugang zu ihm als sie vermutlich ich
dass ist auch sachlich glaube ich nicht
erste eine koexistenz ermöglich und dazu
sich schwergetan am anfang steht aber
ganz richtig ist wir haben nicht den
putin in kiew zurückgeschlagen hat putin
stadt raus zu kommen mit einem völlig
ich haben journalisten die pflicht das
der bundeskanzler vor wird das die
öffentlichen und parlamentarischen oder
dazu bereit wäre womöglich aber das was
dann begonnen heißt ganz klar war was
deutschland wichtiger als die ukraine
jetzt liefern vielen dank frau gottes
kaputten auto mussten an sämtliche
jetzt auch geschlossen woanders die fdp
seine erste vernichtende niederlage
stunde der wahrheit für urlaub das ist
wir sind blank rasiert
das hat der heeresinspekteur gesagt die
bundeswehr steckt seit ganz vielen
jahren in der mangelwirtschaft und
schiebt sachen hin und her und ist nicht
voll ausgestattet das ist bekannt also
dieses 100 milliarden paket kam nicht
umsonst
aber es ist natürlich darüber hinaus
dann durch die frage sag ich einerseits
ja die bundeswehr hat nichts mehr was ja
von herrn scholzen frau lambrecht so
gesagt wird
auf der anderen seite könnte ich
natürlich sachen auch anderswo
beschaffen wenn ich das sagen würde wenn
ich meinen willen dran setzen würde das
heißt es nicht geht kann ich dann auch
an die öffentlichkeit gehen und sagen
geht nicht weil wir kriegen keine
munition oder wir kriegen das zeug nicht
so schnell wieder aufgemöbelt ich glaube
da ist vielleicht einer der kritikpunkte
an herrn scholz dass er da einfach nicht
tragen uhr kommuniziert
dann gehen wir nach winterberg dort ist
martin baethge am telefon herr bitte
seien sie gegrüßt und wir sind gespannt
auf ihre anmerkung ja schön munter wenig
runde ich finde die meisten sind wir gar
nicht bewusst mit solch einem pulverfass
putin spielen wo den führerschein
brauchen von moskau bis berlin fünf bis
zehn minuten vor moskau nach paris 10
bis 15 minuten er vertrat die natur
nicht was sie dem entgegensetzen könnte
diese und darüber spitze ich jetzt noch
nicht mal drastisch für die berliner
blieben noch zeit zum vaterunser und für
die franzosenzeit für ein
glaubensbekenntnis ist ihnen persönlich
und ihr frage ich habe jeden einzelnen
in ihrer runde ist ihnen persönlich die
ukraine es wert dass durch auch schwere
waffenlieferungen sie die gefahr ein
gehen dass deutschland schauplatz eines
wahrscheinlich atomaren krieges wird
gibt es mal zunächst an sie herr geiger
mutiert ja ja das ist
ich sage die ganze zeit schauen man muss
bei der ganzen sache abwägen aber das
habe ich auch einen letzten presseclub
schon gesagt
aber das als totschlagargument zu nehmen
damit man gar nichts macht das ist halt
schwierig und das macht deutschland und
wenn ich eine zeitenwende ankündige und
die zeitenwende betrifft ja nicht nur
[Musik]